[Music]
hey everybody my name is Linden arrive
on the CEO of SolarCity I'm very excited
about the products are going to be
announcing today the products you'll see
is a joint collaboration between Solar
City and Tesla I want to thank the team
for really putting this together and
accept some amount I'm really appreciate
their help and getting this done and but
to really understand the vision it's
welcome Elon Musk
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody ya know fuzzy jacket this time
so the I was sort of by just talking
about the reason why we're doing this
which is as made of red we're reaching
record co2 levels
global warming is becoming a serious is
a serious crisis and we need to do
something about that the but just like
with electric cars where yeah
electric cars originally were they
didn't look good they had low range they
didn't have good performance they're
like a golf cart and some people had a
real hard time buying electric cars and
I think you know something similar needs
to happen to to solely really need to
make solar panels as appealing as as
electric cars have become and the you
know like they're saying thing is that
as you see around you are all solar
houses I know if you know that did you
notice yeah so but when talking in
detail about each them but the the goal
is to make have electric or you know
solar roofs that look better than a
normal roof generate electricity out
last longer a better insulation and
actually have a cost and installed cost
that is less than a normal roof plus the
cost of electricity so then then why
would you buy anything else so let's get
into going to get into the details here
so obviously you saw the the chart
they're probably familiar with with the
bat chart that came from from NASA about
how we're in vertical climb on co2
levels and we need to do everything we
possibly can to accelerate the
transition to sustainable energy
so so the goal of Tesla Tesla people
sometimes think of Tesla as an electric
car company but but really the the whole
purpose of Tesla was to accelerate the
advent of sustainable energy it's not as
like it's not like there was a shortage
of car companies in the world the plenty
of good you know gasoline car companies
but there weren't good electric cars
that's that's really what was needed so
they're really three parts to the
solution so we go to what is the future
that that we want it consists of a
really appealing solar roof then combine
that with with storage and with electric
cars so it's a three it's a obvious
three-part solution yeah three-part
solution it's really not that
complicated now you need battery packs
because the Sun does not shine at night
and the the point that we're at right
now is in fact off the transition we're
transitioning from day to tonight it's
dusk and so what's happening is that the
the houses are transitioning from the
roof generating power to the battery
pack this that the power wool producing
power so during the day you fill up the
battery and then at night and in dusk
and dawn you use the battery it's pretty
straightforward really it's like not
that complicated you need you just need
a both/and but but if you have so a
great solar roof and you have a battery
pack in your house and you have an
electric car that's something that
scales worldwide that you can you can
solve the whole energy equation with
that so yeah obviously next slide please
so the pet so we're like to reduce the
power wall to the this is a big step
above the power well one it has twice as
much energy
more than twice as much power so it's a
1414 kilowatt hour energy storage seven
kilowatt power output and just put that
in basic terms you can take a
four-bedroom house and you can have you
can get empower the your fridge the
sockets and lights for a day and if you
have solar on your on your hat on your
house you can power it indefinitely so
that's us with wine and and then we're
on the utility side we've got the power
pack - which similarly doubles the the
energy so it's a turn ten kilowatt hour
capability 50 kilowatt power output and
this this can scale to unlimited size so
it's a in fact we've recently announced
the the biggest utility battery
installation in the world which is going
to be with the Sun California Edison
let's go to the next slide so we have an
80 megawatt hour battery installation
that's being built right now so and then
we're nice one earlier this year which
is for a utility and Hawaii doing 52
megawatt hours you can see a lot more of
these announced over time and I think I
think it's important to prepare people
appreciate that the solution is both
local power generation and utility power
generation it's not one or the other
sometimes this does the solar roof is
positioned as sort of a competitor to
two utilities but we're actually going
to need utility power to increase and
we're going to need local power
generation because if you transition all
energy to two electric that they're
roughly triples the amount of
electricity that's needed so you eat
about a third for transport about a
third for heating and about a third for
what we currently use electricity so the
future is bright for utilities and for
for poor local power generation I would
expect it to be roughly a
a third local power generation roughly
two-thirds utility so it's it's a very
bright future for for utilities and for
rooftop so let's look at take a look at
some of these roofs well as I'm actually
what we're really looking for here is
how do we have a solar roof that is
better than a normal roof that looks
better
lasts longer has better insulation
stating effect and where the cost of
roof plus electricity is less than that
of a normal roof now this is this is
sort of the integrated future you've got
a electric car a power wall and solar
and a solar roof and the key is that it
needs to be beautiful affordable and
seamlessly integrated and then if if all
those things are are true why would you
go any other direction so yeah so we're
gonna show you this is the before shot
of that house over there so that's what
it looked like before now that's old
solar yeah we've got some close-up shots
that we can show and if you look if you
look carefully you can actually see the
the solar cells behind the glass so this
is a textured glass tile if you look
carefully you can see the solar the
solar cells yeah see that
so we have a malfunction on the led so
slick take a look at the next house
alright so the better house is also
solar and that's a sort of a style above
a French slate which is one of the
hardest things to to do is it's
considered one of the best roofs you can
possibly do as a conventional roof so
said well if okay can we make a French
slate roof that's so low that looks as
good or better than a conventional
French slate roof and we're able to do
that as well
that's done with hydrographic printing
so each tile is unique so that it's a
the production process itself makes each
tile especially unique is sort of
special snowflake tile the but the nice
thing is like no two roofs will be the
same so it's not just cookie cutter you
can take any two roofs like that and
they will look different because they
are different
this is the so what the French late
hydrographic looks like and see that
and then the third house is really
transformative because believe it or not
that's what it looked like before so we
changed the roof and it's like whoa put
that roof on we got to change the house
too so that that you know that that tile
is is more of a modern look
and here you can really see as the angle
changes that you can see the solar cells
so here we put a film with micro louvers
on it so that as as the angle changes it
goes from transparent to opaque so from
the vantage point of the street or
anywhere near the house it looks
completely opaque but from the Sun it's
to the Sun it's transparent and then
probably the most pricing one is that
the Tuscan tuscan glass so this is also
solar panels but we put two versions of
the the tuscan glass approach all of the
dark tiles have solar panels so we
interleave a dark and light and then the
dark ones are the ones with solar panels
again you can see that the transparency
changes quite a bit so as you from the
sun's vantage point which tends to be
high angle you can see that the sole of
the solar cells but as you change the
angle to a shallow angle it reverts to
sort of a orangey color
so that so many other advantages of
glass is that we can actually make it a
lot a lot tougher and last longer than a
conventional roof so we're just as a
demonstration video show you what
happens if you drop a drop a big weight
on a conventional roof tile and one of
our glass tiles so so that's the solar
roof point just we wanted to look better
last longer provide better insulation
and cost less all things considered than
a conventional roof that this illicit
market for the current solar systems but
because that if you're building a new
house or you're redoing a roof then this
is the way to go but if you're if you
have a new roof then you're obviously
you'd want to put solar panels on that
roof so there's there's two very
distinct markets and there's about at
four to five million new roofs in the US
every year and I think twenty times that
number worldwide so you can imagine over
time as people replace their roofs with
solar roofs that the whole neighborhood
whatever everyone would have solar like
why wouldn't why wouldn't you over time
every every house would would become a
solar house and it's it's a neighborhood
where the aesthetics actually get better
so where you look around your
neighborhood and that's what you want to
have happen
so the key is really to make to make
solar something desirable where if you
install a solar roof on your house
you're really proud of it you want it
you want to put it on the most prominent
part of the house you want to call your
neighbors over and say check up check
out the suite roof
it's like our phrase that you hear often
but that's that's the Quito people
people really care about their homes
they love their homes and they really
want they want them to be better and I
think taking this approach it can be so
that's that's that's where we're headed
and I hope you agree that's the future
we want
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mission
[Music]
[Music]
I
[Music]
to try on
I love you
I love you
Oh
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
to pass on all
I love you
I love you
I love
you
[Music]
you